this came out last week will smith is
coming out with a book and he's been
releasing little snippets from his
memoir i liked will smith better when i
didn't know all this [ __ ] that's the
thing a lot of people are saying people
are saying that they like jaden pickett
smith and will smith a lot more before
they started being yeah jada's like we
don't like to [ __ ] each other we have an
open relationship it's like oh you guys
are weird as [ __ ] what happened to the
cool will smith and will's like yeah i
was suicidal i'm thinking about killing
my dad it's like whoa
fresh prince say less dude
[Music]
this is uh what
made way around the internet my father
was violent but he also had every game
plan game play recital he was an
alcoholic but he was sober at every
premiere of every movie
you listen to every record okay sounds
like a solid guy likes to drink when i
was nine years old i watched my father
punch my mother inside of her head so
hard that she collabs and saw her spit
blood they all right he divorced when uh
was a teen in 2000 was he a team look he
loved his son but he had the lowest
point of the restroom between smith and
his father came when he was caring for
his uh father near the end of his life
one night as i deadly wheeled him from
his bedroom towards the bathroom when
darkness rose with me the path between
the two rooms goes past the top of the
stairs all right there's a child always
told myself that i would one day avenge
my mother i paused at the top of stairs
i punched him right inside of his head
just kidding
i could shove him down easy to get away
with it as the decades of pain anger
resentment of course everything i shook
my head and proceeded to wheel daddy out
to the bathroom now is he doing so books
you think
cause i don't oh i know i'm not buying
it these are my eyes right now and i'm
underwater
i got skeptical hippo eyes yeah yeah
i don't believe anything like scottie
pippen
calling homeboy racist like all right
dude it's just a lot of this stuff
becomes
although sammy the book ravano talked
about his mother he loved his mother so
much and he literally says
and at one point i just thought you know
she's in so much pain and i thought
about pushing her down the steps and i
think it would have been boom boom boom
boom boom and that would have been
painful but at the end it would have
been peace and i i couldn't do it but i
thought about it but he's also a
straight-up yeah he's a killer he's also
killed nice fresh prince of bel-air yeah
yeah
now is he doing this to become more
relatable which i'm all good dude i like
the view is the highlight
i like to view you're a better person
than the rest of us yeah
and and you know he also said he had
suicidal thoughts or something like that
too yeah he also talked about how he had
once considered suicide and he re
another thing came out about him being
really upset that he
uh had jaden smith in the movie after
earth and it bombed and then that took a
hit to jayden's career shortly while he
was a teen then he asked to be
emancipated it's just a lot of like
little family things oh [ __ ] yeah it's
heavy heavy drama coming out
yeah he's had a pretty good life yep yep
yep still can't believe he's been famous
since he was 14 forever yeah forever and
uh yeah and so
i'm sure that's why i like sure he came
with it struggling that's why i like
leonardo dicaprio he's not out there
he's not like oh i was sad the other
week no professional dude yes and by the
way keeps that small tight group of
friends around him that's always had
those friends who are loyal to the core